jerome boateng ist das thema das bild
was da gestern von ihnen gezeichnet
wurde vom ehemaligen
idole von uns allen als idol der jugend
als der lieblings nach bei der deutschen
dieses bild was in dem prozess gegen ihn
gezeichnet wurde von ihm selber meine
lieben zuschauer es widert mich einfach
schlicht und ergreifend nur an der
weltmeister einen frauenschläger ein
verurteilter frauenschläger nur das ist
unabhängig solange es natürlich noch
rechtskräftig ist der kann revision
einlegen die staatsanwaltschaft hat es
übrigens auch getan denn sie fordert
eine höhere strafe mein punkt den ich
setzen will ein verurteilter
frauenschläger hat seine vorbildfunktion
in der öffentlichkeit für alle zeiten
verspielt und da zum spitzensport diese
vorbildfunktion dazu gehört gibt es nur
eine einzige logische konsequenz sein
neuer verein olympique lyon muss den
vertrag auflösen und alle seine
werbepartner müssen von dem abstand dem
alles andere wäre für mich absurd
jetzt habe ich hier also dieses
minenfeld thema boarding wo jedes
falsche adjektivs
provisorisch gegen einen verwendet
werden kann und ich muss vorausschicken
ich hasse ist carli underberg zu
widersprechen weil uns verbindet eine
tiefe zuneigung zum feld okay weil er
viel besser gespielt hat als ich ich war
vielleicht talentierter aber du hast
früher sich auf den raum gefallen aber
jetzt das thema boateng ich werde da
jetzt einfach ein bisschen vorsichtig
bevor ich das flammen schwert der
moralischen empörung zog denn wenn ich
mit diesen prozessverlauf anschauen und
wenn ich sehe dass es sich um den
bereich des sexualstrafrechts hand wo
die beweiserhebung sehr schwierig ist wo
sie aussage gegen aussage haben wo sie
zeugen haben die sich einander
widersprechen wir waren nicht dabei wir
wissen dass nicht was da gelaufen ist
was ich weiß und jetzt drehte ich mich
um kopf und kragen wenn heute ein mann
von einer frau öffentlich angegriffen
wird dann ist die anschuldigung fast
schon eine verurteilung wir sehen jetzt
den vn gehört und johnny depp da sind ja
die zeitungen voll gewesen mit diesen
anklagen der amber heard der habe sie
auf schlimmste misshandelt jetzt aber
johnny depp ist herausgekommen viele
dieser anschuldigung offenbar falsch von
einem gehört er verklagt sie jetzt die
gerichte scheinen ihm jetzt plötzlich
recht zu geben also ich wäre da einfach
vorsichtigen aber ich muss in diesen
tagen aber tricks und hast noch eine ja
die sonne und ihre unified in wunden wie
realität ist dass frauen hier tagtäglich
von ihren ehemännern und partner hat
jetzt bin ich in rivella und 33 leute
hier die zu unrecht verurteilt werden
das problem ist gewalt gegenüber frauen
und das muss in aller deutlichkeit
angesprochen werden und wenn an ein idol
ein nationalspieler übrigens das thema
muss eigentlich unsere nationale
nationalteam massiv beschäftigen das ist
nicht das erste mal dass wir diese
vorbilder oder was wir meinen sie wären
vorbilder eigentlich auch im abseits
gespielt haben bin ich ein bisserl denke
wenn ich an manuel neuer denke wenn ich
jetzt an boateng denke da sind für
millionen von kinder und jugendlicher
unsere idole unsere vorbilder was sie
tragen wird getragen von jugendlicher
was sie machen wird gemacht von
jugendlicher und deshalb finde ich
absolut richtig jemand der verurteilt
wegen gewalt gegenüber frauen seine
partnerin und er hat ja andere
geschichten die ich hier nicht erwähnen
will dann muss das konsequenzen haben
und vor allem unserer der
nationalmannschaft muss seine
hausaufgaben machen wie er mit solchen
situationen umgehen ob das
bilder mit erdogan gehen ob das
rechtsradikaler nationaler
nationalistische lieder sind oder in
diesem fall dann verhalten gewalt voller
verhalten gegenüber frauen
als kommunikations experte ist das
natürlich eine sehr schwierige situation
also denn da kann man ja nicht nur
verlieren
jede anschuldigung die es gibt ob
berechtigt oder unberechtigt hat das
gericht jetzt gegen bord hing im sinne
der seiner ehemaligen partnerin
entschieden
wenn auch in erster instanz aber sie hat
das gericht hatte entschieden führt dazu
dass derjenige der beklagt wird oder
beschuldigt wird größte schwierigkeiten
hat den öffentlichkeit erklären dass er
unschuldig ist oder möglicherweise dass
ich das anders abgespielt war das war
hat dass wir offenbar in diesem fall
nach aussagen von boateng der vor
hergestellt das anders da er hat ja noch
nicht mal alles dementiert sondern hat
gesagt das war nicht so schlimm und
irgendwie anders also das ist schon ganz
schwierige situation
also so halb ich war ja in diesem falle
oder um nicht passendes beispiel zu
nehmen geht ja eigentlich nicht und dann
folgt natürlich das was keine unterberg
hier zum besten gegeben hat die totale
verdammung nur das macht sich ja auch
gut gerade jetzt haben eine tochter
hätte ich
hier sage ich okay ich glaube das ist
auch innere überzeugung ist aber
natürlich auch es gibt auch natürlich
diese dieser haltung die einfach doch
zusätzlich da gemacht wird damit man
natürlich auch in diesem falle wer sich
entsprechend auf springt also man kann
da nur verlieren und führt an einem
bordell eine ganz schwierige situation
das beste was er machen konnte war ins
ausland zu gehen
der klub bei dem er ist ist ja sogar
champions league
qualifikant also kein schlechter ich
hoffe für ihn dass er dann wie ich raus
wenn ich also noch ein ganz wichtiger
punkt da muss man noch einflechten ich
kenne worten nicht ich kenne seine story
nicht ich weiß ich habe nur diesen fall
an ich sehe das ist ein ganz ist immer
schwierig in diesen fällen zu teilen ein
punkt den wir noch nicht angesprochen
haben der mich stutzig gemacht hat in
dieser ganzen eindeutigkeit in dieser
ganzen empörung die empörung ist eben
ein schlechter rat geben man muss das
ganz nüchtern anschauen
ein gericht hat boateng das sorgerecht
der zwillinge zugesprochen in dieser
beziehung unter frage mich dann schon
ist jetzt hier diese ganze sachlage so
eindeutig wie das dargestellt wird und
warum hat dann ein gericht schon mal
tempo hat denkt das sorgerecht für die
zwillinge zugewiesen was wir ein extrem
selten der fall ist das nicht die frau
diese der sorgerecht bekommt nochmal ich
kenne den fall nicht ich war nicht dabei
ob ich warne davor dass die richter von
einer vorstufe diesen reden so eindeutig
einfach überhaupt das wort hängen da
komplett alleine schuld ist dass diese
beziehung wie es immer heißt toxisch war
dazu gehören zwei personen fakt ist es
gibt für mich eine ganz klare rote linie
das ist eine frau eine zu bremsen und
das hat auch gut das hat das gericht ja
nun offen sie heiliger das gericht mit
laura @ twitter hat das einfach mal rein
erstes jahr bei einzige stelle und haben
uns gerade sache nicht so recht was er
sagt und sich gefreut das ist kein
letztes tor
was läuft denn die staaten die
staatsanwaltschaft hat ja selber auch
schon berufung eingelegt weil sie das
urteil von 1,8 millionen spricht 30
tagessätze der mann verdient als sehr
gut selber als zu wenig geachtet
insofern scheint sich die stadt hat er
sicher zu sein aber egal sie haben
völlig recht es ist noch nicht beide
seiten auch noch zuschauer im letzten
jahrzehnt warum so angesprochen aber es
geht ja hier überhaupt nicht um den
promi status an sich sondern das
passiert leider um uns herum um das
gebäude herum wahrscheinlich jetzt
gerade in diesem moment also eine frau
hoss lecker opfer häuslicher gewalt wird
und wenn wir nicht das klar anprangern
und der junge herr sich mit 1,8
millionen kaufen oder auch weiter
fußball spielen da quasi schwamm drüber
das will ich ein dramatischer 23 mag
okay aber da haben sie natürlich recht
im grundsätzlich aber ist das
gefährliche argumentation von ihnen sie
können nicht sagen aufgrund von diesen
anderen missständen müssen wir jetzt bei
einem anderen fall sozusagen nicht so
genau hinschauen wie es wirklich gewesen
ist übernehmen ist diesen boateng
sozusagen stellvertretend für all diese
anderen telefon ruhig nein
hier entscheidet die eine frau auf jeden
fall jetzt will alle uns ist jetzt erst
mal gleich bis gleich redest du wieder
gern ein ich bin hier der einzige mit
dieser unsere meinung man muss mein und
es stand er nicht gehört und ich selbst
ich als frau weiß gerade noch nicht wem
ich jetzt hier zustimmen und jetzt
machen wir schluss werden von hermann
suhr und dann zum thema nein der schluss
also wenn sie doch dazu was sagen wollt
ihr das gefühl
es geht nicht um posten es geht hier um
eine vorbildfunktion und wer vor ein
nationalmannschafts spiel oder gespielt
hat trägt verantwortung und in diesem
fall hat er versagt was verantwortung
angeht und deshalb bin ich dafür dass
die nationalmannschaft konzepte
entwickelt zum umgang mit solchen
phänomenen weil es ist kein einzelfall
dort hängen die männer
nationalmannschaft natürlich unterstützt
[Musik]